[Musica]
tecnologia
noi siamo circondati dalla tecnologia
il computer è diventato il nostro
compagno di viaggio il cellulare la
nostra appendice utilizziamo automobili
iper tecnologiche
se dobbiamo andare da qualche parte
digitiamo l'indirizzo sul cellulare o
sul navigatore perché sappiamo che il
cps ci porterà esattamente dove vogliamo
arrivare
e se dobbiamo fare un controllo e
andiamo in ospedale non ci preoccupiamo
secci distendono sul lettino e ci
infilano in un tunnel per fare una tac
piuttosto che una risonanza magnetica o
un esame di medicina nucleare tecnologia
e come ci siamo arrivati e la tecnologia
ci riempie di immagini
noi viviamo di immagini siamo bombardati
di immagini ci siamo le idee con le
immagini sviluppiamo i concetti con le
immagini il 2016 è l'anno delle onde
gravitazionali l'infinitamente grande
chi di noi non ha mai visto le
bellissime immagini le fotografie del
telescopio hubble che ci mostra le
profondità dell'universo
sono immagini che ci affascinano perché
ci parlano di chi siamo da dove veniamo
dove andiamo
infinitamente grande nel 2012 tutti
abbiamo imparato che cos'è il bosone di
higgs e abbiamo visto le immagini
dell'infinitamente piccolo degli
acceleratori di particelle come lhc dove
gli esperimenti scattano 40 milioni di
fotografia al secondo con decine di
miliardi di pixel per farci vedere cosa
succede quando due protoni si scontrano
e producono un bosone di higgs
l'infinitamente piccolo e poi l'uomo il
23 dicembre del 1895 il rettore di
un'università tedesca pubblica la prima
radiografia della storia la radiografia
della mano di sua moglie
il 23 dicembre 1895 nasce la medicina
moderna fino a quella data per guardarvi
nella pancia via privano la pancia da
quella data vi fanno una radiografia e
in 70 anni siamo stati capaci di far
girare un tubo raggi ics tutti intorno
al paziente per farlo ha tante fettine
che messe insieme ci fanno vedere
all'interno del suo corpo come se fosse
aperto di fronte a noi la tacca qualche
anno dopo il 1895 siamo negli anni 30 40
più o meno nasce un altro ramo della
medicina diagnostica la medicina
nucleare
quel ramo della diagnostica che vuol
vedere come funziona il vostro corpo e
non come è fatto abbiamo trasformato i
pazienti in sorgenti radioattive per
scoprire gli hot spot c'è quelle zone
particolarmente attive che possono
essere il vice di qualcosa che non va
l'immagine che vedete alle mie spalle
non è fantasia
nell'immagine di un paziente a cui
abbiamo fatto una tac è un esame di
medicina nucleare una tomografia a
emissione di positroni tecnologia e
immagini come ci siamo arrivati
come siamo arrivati a questo livello di
sviluppo
abbiamo osservato la natura abbiamo
capito come funziona e l'abbiamo usata e
quegli occhiali abbiamo dovuto costruire
per riuscire ad osservare
l'infinitamente grande e l'infinitamente
piccolo tutto quello che ci circonda è
anche quello che sta dentro di noi
gli occhiali che abbiamo costruito e
continueremo a costruire per osservare
la natura si chiamano rivelatori di
particelle e non ho sbagliato il termine
il rilevatore è la persona che di
telefono per sapere quante volte
voi avete latte in una settimana
rivelatore allo stesso significato della
parola inglese detector che deriva dal
latino delle cere togliere il coperchio
scoperchiare togliere la coperta
togliere lenzuolo i rivelatori sono ciò
che ci fa togliere il velo alla natura
per riuscire a capire come funziona io
sono un fisico che sviluppa rivelatore
di particelle e la cosa incredibile è
che per osservare l'infinitamente grande
e l'infinitamente piccolo e tutto quello
che ci circonda
si usano gli stessi rivelatori basati
sugli stessi principi ne esistono di
incredibilmente diversi ne esistono
grandi come lunga del mio dito mignolo
come quelli che stanno nei vostri
cellulari quando fate una foto o come
quelli che sono arrivati su come i
robottini su marte per andare a vedere
di che cosa sono fatte le rocce di marte
ne esistono di un po più grandi come
quelli che io ho messo su satellite
agile che sta girando 500 km di altezza
piastrelline di 10 x 10 centimetri che
hanno riempito un cubo di un metro di
lato
ne esistono di decisamente grandi come
quelli per studiare l'infinitamente
piccolo come quelli di lhc cms pesa 7
mila tonnellate
atlas e 20 x 20 x 30 metri cubi sembra
incredibile ma per studiare
l'infinitamente piccolo costruiamo delle
cose che sono sempre più grandi e sempre
più complesse e poi ne esistono di
decisamente extra large tutti quelli che
servono per studiare le particelle rare
che arrivano dalle profondità
dell'universo o quelle particolarmente
elusive ciascuno di noi
ogni secondo è attraversato da svariati
miliardi di neutrini e non se ne accorge
chi vuole studiare i neutrini ha bisogno
di grandi quantità di materiali e allora
usa l'intera atmosfera terrestre o
riempie di acqua una miniera o utilizza
la luce che neutrini ammettono quando
interagiscono con l'acqua del mare
rivelatori di particelle i nostri
occhiali ma non basta
non basta perché se ci pensate i
rivelatori non ci fanno vedere un
fenomeno ci fanno vedere un prodotto voi
non vedete le mie corde vocali voi
sentite il suono delle che emesso dalle
mie corde vocali
noi non vediamo i gruppi che fondono del
sole vediamo la luce che deriva da
quella fusione non vediamo i due protoni
che si scontrano lhc vediamo le decine
di milioni di canali di elettronica che
si accendono e che ci dicono cosa è
successo quando di protoni si sono
scontrati i rivelatori di particelle ci
fanno vedere un prodotto dal prodotto
dobbiamo dedurre il fenomeno lo dobbiamo
inquadrare in una teoria perché è fare
previsioni perché se la teoria non fa
previsioni rimane un bel volo della
mente verificare le previsioni se
funzionano bene sennò ricominciamo da
capo
questa è stata la nostra ricetta
vincente la nostra ricetta vincente è
stato mettere insieme l'osservazione che
una cosa che facciamo qui rivelatori con
l'inquadramento in una teoria che è una
cosa che facciamo con la nostra
intuizione e la nostra creatività e
abbiamo raccontato la natura
volete degli esempi tutti conosciamo il
big bang tutti sappiamo che 13.7
miliardi di anni fa c'è stato uno
scoppio tra virgolette in cui una
quantità immensa di
energia a una temperatura elevatissima
10 alla 32 gradi kelvin si è trasformata
in materia prima i costituenti delle
particelle elementari poi le particelle
elementari
i protoni sono nati un microsecondo dopo
il big bang dieci alla meno 6 secondi
noi e tutto quello che ci circonda è
fatto di quei protoni lì noi siamo fatti
dei protoni del big bang e poi tutte le
altre particelle elementari gli atomi le
molecole di elementi via via fino a 13.7
miliardi di anni dopo
l'universo come ce l'ha fatto conoscere
il telescopio hubble decisamente più
freddino rispetto a quando è nato questa
è una bellissima teoria ma le teorie
hanno bisogno di verifiche questa teoria
ha avuto tantissime verifiche io ve ne
racconto una che secondo me è
importantissima ed è fantastica negli
anni 50 negli jersey negli stati uniti è
stata costruita un'antenna che si
chiamava un dell'antenna per un progetto
di telecomunicazioni stiamo parlando di
telecomunicazioni onde radio le
conosciamo tutti
tutti sappiamo cos'è un antenna radio
progetto si chiamava ecco c'erano dei
satelliti che si comunicavano quando
progetto si completa e ben telecom lapse
due fisici robert wilson e hanno pensi
al decidono di modificare l'antenna per
captare le onde radio sempre on the
radio si tratta dalle profondità della
via lattea
nel 1964 la accendono la girano in tutte
le direzioni continuano sentire un
fastidioso ticchettio a quel punto
prendono il telefono telefonano
princeton dove c'era uno dei maggiori
teorici della teoria del big bang robert
chi lui risponde mette giù il telefono
si gira verso i collaboratori e dice ci
hanno battuto sul tempo prende la
macchina e li raggiunge robert wilson e
arno penzias avevano scoperto la
radiazione cosmica di fondo quando
l'universo ha compiuto 380.000 anni anno
più anno meno è diventato trasparente
a quel punto la luce ha potuto uscire la
radiazione cosmica di fondo e la
candelina che l'universo ha soffiato
quando ha compiuto 380.000 anni 13.7
miliardi di anni fa la radiazione
cosmica di fondo isotropa uniforme in
tutte le direzioni pensate
da un telo teso in realtà già delle
piccolissime fluttuazioni l'immagine che
vedete alle mie spalle appena arriva
el'immagine raccolta dal satellite v
mappa della nasa i puntini gialli e
rossi sono le fluttuazioni della
radiazione cosmica di fondo i puntini
gialli e rossi sono i semini delle
stelle e delle galassie di oggi gli
occhiali stiamo parlando di onde radio
ma stiamo parlando di cose
stratosferiche gli occhiali che abbiamo
costruito per misurarle ci permettono di
leggere un libro di 13.7 miliardi di
anni fa
incredibile all'inizio del 1900 i fisici
entrano in crisi
entrano in crisi perché non riescono a
capire come la luce la materia possono
parlarsi la luce un'onda che pervade
tutto lo spazio infinitamente la materia
fatta di corpuscoli infinitamente
piccoli che sono gli atomi allora come
fa questa onda interagire
istantaneamente con gli elettroni che
stanno degli altri che stanno nella mia
retina e questo succede perché io vedo e
tra l'altro gli occhi sono l'esempio più
antico del rivelatore di particelle
realizzato in diversi miliardi di coppie
più o meno funzionanti
allora allora cosa capiscono che le
osservazioni erano corrette ma
l'interpretazione no è il binomio la
vittoria la ricetta vincente loro
capiscono che le osservazioni sono
corrette allora dicono vuol dire che
quando ci spostiamo verso il micromondo
l'infinitamente piccolo le leggi che
abbiamo scritto per inquadrare quello
che osserviamo in ciò che ci circonda
non funzionano più tanto bene dobbiamo
cambiarla perché nel micro mondo le onde
sono particelle e le particelle sono
onde pensate la difficoltà dal punto di
vista dell'intuizione ben prima di
formalizzare di immaginare una cosa del
genere le onde sono particelle le
particelle sono onde
da qui nasce tutta la nostra tecnologia
la aver pensato questo e poi averlo
formalizzato aver capito che la natura
veramente funziona così ci ha portato a
sviluppare occhiali sempre più potenti
volete un esempio tutti voi avete
utilizzato il microscopio ottico una
sorgente luminosa
il campione è una
riguardate il vostro be campione due
dimensioni ma se invece della sorgente
luminosa io utilizzo gli elettroni li
strappo dagli atomi come delle biglie
perché tanto biglie sono lì accelero con
una differenza di potenziale perché
tanto biglie solo e poi li mando a
sbattere contro il campione quando
arrivano lì ci arrivano con un'energia
per cui si comportano con un fascio di
luce con una lunghezza d'onda molto più
piccola della luce visibile
e allora vuol dire che vedo campioni più
piccoli ma rimangono pur sempre delle
biglie cariche e allora vuol dire che
con facilità posso anche fare una
scansione e ottenere la terza dimensione
questo è il principio su cui funziona
microscopio elettronico a scansione e le
immagini che produce sono come quelle
che state vedendo le mie spalle che è
l'immagine della bocca di un all'alfa
occhiali rivelatori di particelle
ma la cosa ancora più affascinante è che
i rivelatori che andiamo utilizzare per
vedere di elettroni che hanno interagito
con la larva con la bocca della l'arma
sono gli stessi che stanno nei vostri
cellulari per farla foto sono gli stessi
che sono andati su marte sono gli stessi
che mettiamo nella zona in cui i protoni
si scontrano per ricostruire le tracce
sono gli stessi che io ho caricato sul
satellite agile che sta girando a 500
chilometri d'altezza in orbita
equatoriale osservando le profondità
dell'universo come un atto della nasa ma
una lunghezza d'onda diversa i raggi
gamma
pensateci come leggere il libro
dell'universo scritto in un'altra lingua
e sono gli fanno parte della stessa
famiglia di quelli che usiamo per farvi
una tac e sono rivelatori che ci
permettono di studiare e conservare il
passato nel 1970 è stato scoperto il
papiro di indie ti piuttosto che un
papiro un mucchietto di cenere era poco
più grande di una moneta assolutamente
inutilizzabile non si poteva manipolare
sarebbe andato in mille pezzi e sarebbe
stato perso
è di poche settimane fa la notizia che
un gruppo di ricercatori statunitensi e
insieme a un gruppo di ricercatori
israeliani ha deciso di fargli una micro
tac una micro tac preclinica come quelle
che si usa in ospedale tuba raggi ics
che gira intorno al macchietto di cena
tante fettine una volta fatte le fettine
la stessa cosa adesso si sta facendo con
i gruppi italiani per i papiri di
ercolano hanno applicato un algoritmo di
anne wrapping virtuale in tre dimensioni
e sono riusciti a leggerlo scoprendo che
una copia del libro del levitico anzi
pare che sia la più antica coppia di un
libro del pentateuco mai trovato in
un'arca sacra la datazione con il
carbonio 14 dice che del terzo quarto
secolo dopo cristo rivelatori gli
occhiali e l'interpretazione che ne
diamo ci hanno permesso di capire che la
natura è un puzzle molto articolato con
tanti pezzi
qualcuno ha intuito il disegno qualcuno
ha sistemato qualche pezzo qualcuno ne
ha trovato di nuovi quel che è certo è
che lo scopo finale per chi come me
sviluppa rivelatori di particelle e per
tutti coloro che analizzano la mole
incredibile di dati che questi
rivelatori raccolgono rimane sempre lo
stesso migliorare la vita dell'uomo a
360 gradi
lo diceva anche einstein in mezzo a
tutti i vostri diagrammi i vostri
esperimenti i vostri laboratori
ricordatevi dell'uomo quello che
facciamo lo facciamo per il nostro il
vostro futuro quello che facciamo lo
facciamo per il futuro dell'uomo
grazie
[Applauso]